we must hold these people accountable
and unfortunately we didn't I mean if we
learned One Thing by these midterm
elections Gretchen Whitmer in Michigan
got re-elected Kathy hochel in New York
got reelected Gavin Newsom in California
got reelected these people seem to want
more and the signal that you send to
authoritarians when you say hey
authoritarians oh you're you're really
taking care of me you're really doing
all these things so that I'm locked in
my house and I can't go to work and
you're destroying everything but I guess
I kind of like it because perhaps I have
some sort of other existential problem
that I should really be thinking about
instead then you vote them back in and
they will do it again so in Los Angeles
California Los Angeles Public Health
director Barbara Ferrer she looks like
death and if you would like to get your
health advice from someone that looks
like death then I highly recommend you
listen to Barbara Ferrer anyway she
wants to bring back indoor masking it's
probably going to kick in next week if
both Hospital indicators the new
covid-19 Admissions and the proportion
version of staffed inpatient beds
occupied by coveted patients surpasses
the threshold for high and our case rate
is at or above 200 new cases per hundred
thousand people
LA County will follow the CDC guidance
for communities designated at the high
Community level including Universal
indoor masking
I live in Florida
insane you know it's almost one year to
the day December 17th was the day that
we got here December 17th what's today
the 12th yeah we're right there
um congratulations if you live in LA
like get the hell out or just like go go
down with the ship enough of these crazy
people